je ne serai pas un montreur de
foire je ne ferai pas de promesse
inconsidéré je ne tomberai pas dans
[Musique]
l'europessimisme il ne peut pas y avoir
d'Europe si les citoyens ne peuvent pas
circuler librement travailler où ils
veulent
objectif supprimer les frontières entre
les six pays fondateurs de l'Europe la
France l'Allemagne la Belgique le
Luxembourg les Pays-Bas et l'Italie
aboutissement de 5 années de travail la
Convention de Schengen fixe les
conditions d'une libre circulation dès
l'été 92 à l'intérieur des 6 pays
signataires et quand sera-t-il possible
d'aller étudier en Europe quand on veut
et où l'on veut c'est déjà possible
madame voil grâce aux échanges de
Programm dans le cadre d'erasmous dont
madame papa Andreou qui est ici présente
s'occupe et puis nous avons décidé
l'équivalence des diplômes à bac+ 3 déjà
ce qui permettra à chacun de pouvoir
exhiber de son diplôme dans tous les
pays de la Communauté ça c'est l'Europe
des citoyens bonjour je m'appelle
Clément j'ai 22 ans je suis étudiant
Erasmus la rentrée universitaire de
Clément a commencé comme ça
is bin Erasmus nous répète-t-il je suis
un Erasmus comprenait un étudiant
européen Clément le petit frenchy vient
de débarquer à Berlin pour un an disons
que je suis un peu un touriste Erasmus
ça peut non non oui parce que évidemment
la distraction va être majeure mais
quand même quand même je suis là pour
bosser on se poserait même plus la
question si on est français allemand ou
européens on justement les deux et c'est
ça ce qui fait ce qui fait l'Europe
quelque chose de très spécial
[Musique]
le symbole de l'euro c'est un pas
décisif franchi vers une Europe unie une
Europe forte une Europe puissante et
généreuse c'est cela qu'il faut
retenir les
[Applaudissements]
eurieret ben c'est 50 € je sais pas
combien ça fait en franc mais ça fait
plaisir d'avoir des€os en c'est de
l'argent quand
même émotion grande émotion grande
émotion premier billet et alors
qu'est-ce que ça fait
c'est c'est très personnel je peux pas
[Musique]
vous